mais ce pouvoir et la classe politique
face aux bouleversements de l'échiquier
politique français au lendemain des
élections européennes le front national
à égalité avec le parti communiste la
gauche devient globalement minoritaires
ailleurs en europe érosion des partis au
pouvoir en italie le parti communiste
devient la première formation politique
du pays
lis cet attentat à l'explosif la nuit
dernière en corse pour marquer
l'anniversaire de la disparition du
militant nationaliste dit orsoni
dernières encablures dans la transat
anglaise en solitaire à la proche de new
york philippe poupon toujours en tête
devant marc pajot et christophe philippe
madame monsieur bonsoir
l'enjeu de principe de cette élection
avait beau être floue
le taux de participation a eu beau être
médiocre il y a eu un peu plus de 43 %
d'abstention l'élection européenne de
1984 fera date dans l'histoire politique
française
elle cristallise en effet de nouveaux
rapports de force entre les formations
politiques et représente pour la gauche
au pouvoir depuis trois ans un échec
sévère
patrice hier charnelet la liste georges
marchais obtient 11,28 % lionel jospin
20,73 simone veil 42,88 jean marie le
pen 11%
aucune des dix autres listes n'a franchi
la barre des 5% malgré leur nombre plus
élevé qu'en 1979
elles totalisent moins de voix les
écologistes de didier anger obtiennent
un peu plus que la liste animée par
olivier stirn vous le voyez sur ce
tableau
pas plus de succès pour les listes
socioprofessionnelle de francine gomez
ou de gérard touati
sous réserve de la confirmation
définitive et officielle de ses
résultats
les 81 sièges à pourvoir au parlement
européen de strasbourg serait ainsi
attribué 41 pour l'union de l'opposition
20 pour le ps dise pour le pt vis pour
le front national
dans ce scrutin européen d'hier il ya en
effet un seul vainqueur
le président du front national jean
marie le pen avec 11% des voix sa
formation qu'on le veuille ou non
représente maintenant la troisième vrai
composantes de l'opposition
quelles qu'aient été les motivations des
français de tous bords qui ont ainsi
manifesté leur faveur un homme autant
que leur rejet de toute une classe
politique
c'est une belle revanche pour
l'extrême-droite marginalisé dans la vie
politique française depuis la libération
une belle revanche aussi pour un homme
qui aux présidentielles de 74 avait eu
moins de 1% des suffrages et qui n'avait
même pas pu se présenter faute de
parrainages à celle de 81
gérard ine c'est dans le calme de sa
propriété de saint cloud que jean marie
le pen a savouré hier soir son succès
pari gagné non seulement il dépasse la
barre des 10%
mais il se place au même niveau que son
ennemi juré le pc en fait jean marie le
pen avait déjà gagné bien avant dimanche
depuis plus d'un an d'élections en
élections le leader du front national
marque des points
première étape de cette ascension dreux
où pour la première fois des hommes
d'extrême droite entre dans un conseil
municipal
un succès dû d'abord à un habile
d'allant d'exploiter les psychoses de
certains même si jean marie le pen s'en
défend il se trouve que j'ai été décrit
comme l'immonde et spa comme la bête
comme le diable et bien et se trouvent
que les français qui la veille avait
déjà démontré dans le pays où je suis né
qu'il me donnait à 51 % leurs voix ne
pense pas du tout comme les journalistes
ni comme les observateurs politiques
il pense que les libertés sont menacées
non pas par monsieur le pen mais par le
commune
ici ils pensent que l'immigration que le
chômage que la sécurité sont des
problèmes réels et que le pen dit haut
ce que tout le monde pense tout bas
tous les électeurs de jean marie le pen
ne sont pas d'extrême droite 69% de ses
nouveaux partisans avaient voté pour
valéry giscard d'estaing 27 % pour
françois mitterrand
citant d'électeurs ont voté pour le
leader du front national c'est parce
qu'ils approuvent son discours sur la
défense des libertés sur la sécurité et
sur l'immigration les faits le pen a si
bien fonctionné qu'il intéresse
aujourd'hui l'europe entière succès de
curiosité le pen a eu droit hier à la
télévision anglaise
reste à savoir si le leader du front
national va profiter de ce succès pour
s'étendre dans le pays
et s'il va durer ou bien ne s'agit-il
que d'un vote d'humeur en tout cas
l'ascension de jean marie le pen
embarrasse empoisonne même les
formations politiques traditionnelles à
gauche et surtout à droite
l'extrémisme de droite nous n'avions
jamais eu en france depuis depuis 1945
et que en fait on sait très bien ce que
représente l'extrême droite en france
est un courant traditionnelle depuis
fort longtemps
c'est au point du pourcentage de voix
plus de choses et qu'il a fallu ce qui
s'est passé depuis trois ans avec un
gouvernement socialiste pour que deux
tout d'un coup cette ce parti se gonfle
de gens qui ne sont pas des extrémistes
mais qui en ont assez qui sont exaspérés
c'est un ras-le-bol dans parmi
l'électorat de gauche pour des raisons
que l'on peut deviner le cadre de vie
l'environnement
l'épreuve de relations humaines que
surtout tapis parmi la droite les forces
d'extrême droite qu'incarne
le pfn tout cela existait donc c'est une
sortie au grand jour ça n'en est que
plus inquiétant pour la démocratie que
nous constatons c'est que dans les 11 %
d'électeurs qui ont voté pour de chez le
pen la constante de l'extrême droite
c'est toujours 1 2%
le reste ce sont des électrices et des
électeurs qui ont voulu donner une leçon
aux socialistes le pen est sécrétée par
la droite par la politique de la droite
qui devinent longues années la cochlée
gâchis de la police de société la
concentration d'immigrés dans des
ghettos dans des villes ouvrières to
save fournit la base pour que le pen
utilise certains mécontentements les
ajoute et le pen le pen est sécrétée à
votre politique des réactions
enregistrées ce matin lors de notre
édition spéciale ne négligerons pas pour
autant l'autre phénomène marquant du
scrutin d'hier le parti communiste avec
11,28 % des voix enregistre son score le
plus bas depuis 1932
c'est une défaite cinglante pour la
ligne politique imprimé à son parti par
georges marchais que l'on n'a pas vu ni
entendu publiquement depuis qu'il est
elle est votée hier matin serge
demi-frère 22 heures les premières
estimations tombent et les visages se
crispent au siège de l'humanité hier on
ne perçoit pas encore l'ampleur du coût
qui vient de frapper le parti communiste
une première édition du journal titre
forte abstention
l'abstention c'est vrai est importante
mais le recul mais aussi 4 points de
moins qu'en 80 on attendait georges
marchais c'est pierre juquin le porte
parole du pc qu'il y ait un bref
communiqué ce qui vient de se passer est
un avertissement sérieux reconnaît-il
pierre juquin est sous le coup de
l'émotion il a du mal à cacher son
amertume
il faut que nous regardions achats les
motivations qui ont conduit les
électeurs
de gauche à la prise de position en
d'autres termes est ce qu on est pas en
train de rejeter la faute sur le
gouvernement
julien je ne rejette pas la faute sur le
gouvernement constate que les électeurs
se sont prononcés sévèrement
l'ornement quand même accordé la
politique depuis un certain temps et
cette politique n'a pas été l'objet
d'une grande satisfaction des français
c'est une évidence dans la réflexion des
responsables communistes il ya
aujourd'hui des chiffres qui traduisent
une réalité le déclin amorcé en 79 entre
les cantonales et les européennes
il s'est poursuivi au fil des
consultations électorales 80 aux
présidentielles 15,3 légère remontée un
point aux législatives et la descente
continue 15,9 aux cantonales en 82
aujourd'hui 11,2 européenne pour les
communistes français ce qui vient de se
passer est un tournant historique selon
les propres mots de pierre juquin
l'événement il est vrai pose deux
problèmes la succession éventuelle de
georges marchais on parle déjà de
charles fiterman est plus loin peut-être
la présence au gouvernement pour
l'instant du temps au pc on n'en est pas
là les communistes sont encore sous le
choc
réunion exceptionnelle du comité central
dans les prochains jours dès demain
réunion du bureau politique du parti
communiste
bien sûr comme il est de règle après
chaque élection les états majors se
livrer à des calculs savants pour
défendre leurs scores et le discours
politique reprend ses droits
il n'en reste pas moins que la marque
les résultats de cette élection
européennes plongent toutes les
formations politiques dans la majorité
comme dans l'opposition dans l'embarras
le tout paris politique qui nous est
devenu familier
ces hommes qui dirigent les partis
traditionnels sont ce soir perplexe la
personne de jean marie le pen et la
défaite de georges marchais bouleverse
l'échiquier et oblige les deux camps à
méditer sur leur propre stratégie
la gauche tout d'abord comment faire
pour reconquérir l'opinion le parti
socialiste malmené et le parti
communiste groggy se pose la même
question mais il n'apporte pas la même
réponse
pour les socialistes la rigueur est
encore nécessaire elle portera ses
fruits distille après la potion amère
le miel mais les communistes n'y croit
guère il est au contraire urgent à leur
avis de changer de cap la divergence est
totale la gauche devra la résoudre et
marcher d'un même pas au risque de se
perdre
l'opposition se porte mieux en apparence
la famille s'est agrandie
mais le nouveau venu est encombrant
autres bruyant gênant seulement voilà
jean marie le pen dispose depuis 24
heures d'un trésor de guerre plus de
deux millions de voix or le rpr et l'udf
aurons besoin de ces voies en 86 pour
gagner l'élection législative reprendre
le pouvoir
comment faire dans ces conditions pour
récupérer cette manne la raison
politique ou plutôt la logique politique
devrait les inciter à accueillir
l'indésirable mais la morale pense-t-il
le leur interdit un vrai dilemme
déjà à l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui
à l'ouverture du débat en seconde
lecture sur la presse c'est bien qu'il
n'y ait eu que dix neuf députés dans
l'hémicycle
l'opposition a haussé le ton en
demandant en substance au premier
ministre de venir s'expliquer ou de
démissionner la légine la légitimité de
l'équipe gouvernementale en place au
lendemain de cette élection européenne
les causes du revers subi par le parti
socialiste et de la défaite aussi du
parti communiste notamment la politique
de rigueur
autant de questions qui seront
évidemment posé tout à l'heure au
socialiste jacques delors puisque le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
est l'invité ce soir de l'heure de
vérité sur antenne 2 juste après ce
journal comme d'habitude en appelant à
paris le 7 196 svp au fond
vous pourrez poser à monsieur de l'or
vos propres questions même si l'élection
européenne qui contrairement aux autres
en france et fait à la proportionnelle
même si cette élection n'est pas de même
nature qu'une autre scrutin national
le climat politique en france s'en
trouve désormais changé tout comme la
tactique des leaders politiques qu'elle
peut être maintenant la marge de
manoeuvre du premier tacticien de la
classe politique française que peut
faire maintenant
le président mitterrand albert durand
françois mitterrand n'a pas fini de
découvrir des avantages des institutions
de la vème république
elles permettent en effet de continuer à
gouverner en se reposant sur des forces
politiques qui sont devenus minoritaires
dans le pays
avant lui le général de gaulle georges
pompidou et valéry giscard d'estaing en
ont fait l'expérience
mais on sait qu'elle en fut le résultat
pour de gaulle et l'iss car l'échec du
1er en 1969 et du second en 1981 donc
françois mitterrand peut continuer à
gouverner mais il doit réagir comment
pas question pour lui de dissoudre
l'assemblée nationale dans l'état actuel
de l'opinion ce serait suicidaire pour
la gauche pas question non plus de
changer le cap de la politique de
rigueur
il a déjà dit que c'était la seule
possible de plus à l'elysée comme à la
direction du parti socialiste
on est convaincu que seule la réussite
économique peut sauver la gauche
en 1986 il en est convaincu aussi que
les premiers signes de cette réussite ne
vont plus tarder
reste que le président a tout intérêt à
tenir compte du message de
mécontentement que lui a adressée
l'opinion que peut-il faire d'autre
sinon changer de gouvernement
à défaut de modifier le cap de sa
politique
une différence de style peut provoquer
un choc bénéfique
alors qui pour diriger cette équipe un
homme d'ouverture où un homme qui
mobilisera la gauche
et quand la constituer cette équipe tout
de suite durant l'été où seulement après
la session budgétaire de l'automne voilà
les deux questions auxquelles le chef de
l'état doit aujourd'hui répondre tout ce
que l'on peut dire est que le vote
d'hier risque de précipiter les
échéances
dans notre dernier journal à vendre
or 15 de commentateurs politiques
confronteront leur analyse et leur
scénario sur l'avenir alain duhamel
d'europe1 d'antenne 2 et jacques
julliard du nouvel observateur une
modification dans l'équipe
gouvernementale max gallo qui était
jusqu'ici le porte parole du
gouvernement et qui a qui vient d'être
élu à strasbourg sur la liste socialiste
max gallo a remis comme prévu sa
démission
il sera remplacé par roland dumas le
ministre des affaires européennes qui
cumulera les deux fonctions
l'élection d'hier était européenne et il
n'y a pas qu'en france que les résultats
en ont été spectaculaires le phénomène
le plus marquant a été a été enregistré
en italie où une semaine après la mort
de son secrétaire général le parti
communiste italien a été consacrée hier
la première formation politique du pays
victor brown première réunion cet
après-midi avant de la direction du
parti communiste italien après la mort
enrick obert leanware l'un de ses
dirigeants sera certainement désigné
comme successeur est nouveau c'est à
dire général
mais il faut encore l'approbation même
formelle de la commission contrôle des
du comité central donc un peu de
patience
première réunion si des dirigeants
communistes après le dépassement
électorale la démocratie chrétienne pour
la première fois dans l'histoire de la
république dépassement de 0 23 % ce qui
représente exactement 91 1840 et une
joie ce n'est pas décisif mais cela
prend une valeur de symbole curieusement
et alors que la démocratie chrétienne
faire effectivement 3 5% des voix par
rapport aux européennes de 79 elle gagne
un petit 0 1% par rapport aux
législatives de 83
c'est une brillante remontée des
communistes plutôt qu une débâcle de la
démocratie chrétienne
voici comment on explique à la
démocratie chrétienne cette remontée
spectaculaire du parti communiste
italien
premièrement le pci a profité pour ne
pas dire exploiter la mort d'enrico
berlinguer mais il est évident que ce
mouvement de sympathie ne va pas se
prolonger jusqu'aux prochaines élections
législatives
deuxièmement s'il s'était agit justement
d'élections législatives et non pas
européenne
jamais le pci nom est obtenu 33 3% dé
voir c'est en tout cas une explication
raisonnable mais qu'il est bien
difficile évidemment de vérifier dans la
pratique
ailleurs en europe puisque on a
maintenant pratiquement tous les
résultats un constat d'ensemble
les partis au pouvoir ont tous subi la
même érosion surtout en grande-bretagne
et en allemagne fédérale
le centre droit conservera néanmoins à
strasbourg la majorité absolue dans la
nouvelle assemblée bernard benaïem tels
que se présente la nouvelle assemblée
européenne appelle trois remarques
la première c'est le maintien d'une
majorité du centre et de droite même si
elle perd 21 sièges
élections européennes de 1979 cette
majorité obtient 2 119 sièges
deuxième remarque le parti socialiste
reste le groupe le plus nombreux avec
130 sièges dont 5 gagnés hier
en revanche le parti communiste perd six
sièges
malgré le score historique du pc italien
les communistes européens ne sont plus
désormais que 40 2 troisième remarque
enfin cette assemblée marque l'entrée en
force de deux nouveaux courants les
verts les écologistes qui obtiennent 11
sièges et l'extrême droite qui en a 16
dont 10 français
cela dit comme c'est le cas pour chaque
consultation européenne le scrutin
d'hier a été marquée par une abstention
élevée et par un recul général des
majorités au pouvoir ainsi en
grande-bretagne
les conservateurs de margaret thatcher
subissent un revers assez nette
ils perdent 17 sièges au profit de
l'opposition travailliste et là encore
les motivations de politique intérieure
ont joué pleinement neil kinnock le
leader du parti travailliste estimé
tiers soit que ces élections constituent
est une leçon pour un gouvernement qui a
maîtrisé les chômeurs et laisser dépérir
les services sociaux
même tonalité en allemagne fédérale où
les conséquences du scrutin d'hier
pourrait être encore plus grave puisque
c'est la coalition gouvernementale qui
est ébranlée car si les
chrétiens-démocrates et les sociaux
chrétiens ne perdre qu'un sièges dans la
nouvelle assemblée européenne
en revanche c'est le très mauvais score
des libéraux la troisième composante de
la coalition qui pourrait remettre en
cause leur participation au pouvoir
d'autant que pour aggraver ce changement
du paysage politique en allemagne
fédérale les verts les écologistes font
une entrée en force au parlement
européen
cette députée pas moins pour ce parti
avec lequel le chancelier kohl va devoir
compter très rapidement le chancelier
kohl n'a pas l'intention de procéder à
un remaniement de son gouvernement c'est
ce qu'il a déclaré aujourd'hui dans une
conférence de presse
en allemagne la grève pour la semaine de
35 heures
entre dans sa sixième semaine et 42
mille salariés de plus la région de
stuttgart sont frappés par l'extension
du local a décidé aujourd'hui par le
patronat de la métallurgie violents
affrontements aujourd'hui en grande
bretagne entre mineurs et policiers 57
personnes ont été blessées dont le
président du syndicat des mineurs une
centaine d'autres interpellés par la
police ce sont les plus graves incidents
en plus de trois mois de grève des
mineurs britanniques
il y avait des élections hier aussi en
pologne des élections municipales la
direction clandestine de solidarité
avaient appelé au boycottage de ces
élections mais le gouvernement
aujourd'hui crient victoire selon son
porte parole
au moins 75 % des électeurs y auraient
participé
gérard ce bague le boycott était le
moyen préconisée par lech walesa et
solidarité pour récuser le gouvernement
de monsieur jarre ou jet ski lesieu lech
walesa a clamé hier à gdansk s'est rendu
à la messe dominicale mais pas aux
bureaux de vote sont après-midi s'est
passé à la cueillette aux champignons
une élection sans surprise oui il n'ya
que des candidats officiels les taux de
participation permettent donc de moules
ville de mesurer la popularité du
mouvement solidarité au cours des
élections précédentes 99 % des polonais
s'étaient rendus aux urnes hier ils
étaient 75 % le gouvernement polonais
annonce l'échec du boycottage mais 24 %
d'abstention c'est beaucoup dans un pays
où il est facile de contrôler les
votants surtout quand l'abstention prend
une nette coloration de refus
dans un communiqué publié aujourd'hui
les évêques polonais manifestent leur
inquiétude devant l'augmentation des
arrestations en pologne pour raisons
politiques en turquie deux autres
détenus d'extrême gauche sont morts en
prison il faisait depuis deux mois la
grève de la faim pour protester contre
la torture et les sévices subis dans les
prisons militaires d'istanbul en quatre
jours quatre grévistes de la faim sont
donc morts en turquie
ses rêves ni aujourd'hui au mont
valérien aujourd'hui 18 juin pour le 44e
anniversaire de l'appel du général de
gaulle le président mitterrand et son
premier ministre lui ont rendu hommage
patrick lecocq
juin 1940 pour la france la guerre est
finie
son armée a été humilié les soldats
allemands défile sur les champs elysées
plus de la moitié du pays est occupée
bientôt vichy remplacera pas et pourtant
alors que jamais l'avenir n'a été aussi
sombre à londres ce 18 juin 1940 une
voix s'élèvent celle du général de
gaulle la flamme de la résistance
française ne doit pas s'éteindre et ne
s'éteindra pas entendre les français
la suite chacun la connaît et quatre ans
plus tard en juin 1944 les troupes
françaises seront aux côtés des soldats
alliés
pour participer à la libération du
territoire
le président de la république ainsi que
de nombreux membres du gouvernement
étaient il y à quelques minutes devant
le mémorial du mont valérien
une commémoration traditionnelle en
présence de près de 300 compagnons de la
libération de l'appel du 18 juin
mais aussi rappelle du sacrifice des
capots 1500 patriotes fusillés ici et au
travers d'eux de tous ceux qui de 1940 à
1945 donnèrent leur vie dans la lutte
clandestine contre l'occupant c'est un
anniversaire d'une tout autre nature que
les militants corses de l'ex flnc ont
célébré à leur manière en corse du sud
l'année dernière ni cet attentat qui
n'ont pas encore été revendiqué ces
attentats ont marqué le premier
anniversaire de la disparition du
militant nationaliste guy orsoni
surplace hervé brusini on n'avait pas vu
cela en corse depuis plusieurs mois
d'abord vers 00h07 une première charge
qui explose dans les locaux de gaz de
france et puis une deuxième place et
sous cette voiture un policier accouru
sur les lieux est fortement choquée par
la déflagration
quant au gardien de nuit présents cette
nuit-là c'est la sixième fois qu'il
assiste à un tel plasticage et ma foi il
ne s'en étonne pas ça représente 7 à
français en quelques mois pour chaque
français
ils ont donc aussi fait sauter la
perception d'ajaccio de même que des
banques
quelques voitures
en tout 17 plasticage en un peu plus de
deux heures à porto vecchio deux poseurs
de bombes ont même été pris sur le fait
toutes les cibles visées semble désigner
l'auteur de cette mais bleu l'ex flnc
les enquêteurs en sont persuadés le
commissaire broussard affirmé ce matin
qu'il s'attendait bien à ce que quelque
chose se passe en ce jour anniversaire
un an après la disparition de guillaume
au pays basque les quatre membres
présumés du gal gardé à vue depuis deux
jours à bayonne ont avoué aujourd'hui
être les auteurs ou les complices de
l'attentât à l'explosif survenu vendredi
dernier à biarritz et quatre hommes ont
été inculpés attentats à l'explosif la
nuit dernière à paris contre un
commissariat de police rue de rivoli
dans le 4e arrondissement
l'explosion n'a pas fait de victime mais
des dégâts matériels importants
cet attentat n'a pas été revendiqué
jusqu'ici un nouveau sursis pour creusot
loire le tribunal de commerce de paris a
renvoyé au 21 juin sa décision sur
l'avenir du groupe le numéro un français
de la mécanique lourde qui vous le savez
est au bord du dépôt de bilan
un conseil d'administration doit avoir
lieu demain au siège de la société
inculpation du président de l'amm rep
cette société de forage pétrolier en mer
qui est en règlement judiciaire depuis
15 jours il était inculpé d'infraction à
la législation sur les sociétés pour
avoir publié des informations fausses
sur la marche de son entreprise
encore un mort hier dans une course à
cheval le jockey guyenot qui courait à
auteuil
hier après midi est mort sur
l'hippodrome à la suite d'une chute
ce sont les dernières heures les
dernières finesse à la barre dans la
transat anglaise en solitaire les
premiers concurrents approche ce soir de
newport sur la côte est des états unis
toujours en tête le français philippe
poupon et son trimaran suivi du
catamaran de marc pajot le poids de la
course avec notre envoyé spécial ont
régalé
après l'autre à 1000 kilomètres de
traversée les concurrents en tête de la
transat prendre l enfant depuis 24
heures bien difficile de faire des
pronostics
le dernier pointage du partenaire et les
poupons en tête avec 24 milles d'avancé
sur marc pajot 42000 sur peter phillips
et 44 milles sur eric tabarly
dans une communication téléphonique
pageau a donné sa position estimé à cent
milles de la ligne d'arrivée dans la
meilleure hypothèse les bateaux
devraient arriver demain dans la matinée
alors de paris iv et voyez dans un
mouchoir de poche et quelques autres
affaires sérieuses notamment il vous
faut cogner susceptible de créer la
surprise
en effet le jury de course qui a octroyé
un bonus de 16 heures le temps qu'il a
passé près des açores pour porter
assistance à philippe blondeau à colmar
fauconnier rattrape le quarté de tête et
ne possède plus que 100 milles de retard
sur ce site vous passez dans mille 180
km l'arrivée est en fait prévenus vers
minuit c'est ce que vient de m'apprendre
en régaler qui vient de survoler en
hélicoptère les premiers concurrents et
qui confirme aussi la vence de philippe
poupon football frau championnat
d'europe des nations michel hidalgo
vient de communiquer la composition de
l'équipe de france qui rencontrera la
yougoslavie demain soir au stade
geoffroy-guichard saint-etienne
le match sera retransmis en direct sur
antenne 2 à partir de 20h20 de
changement dans cette équipe française
jean-marc ferreri à la place de bernard
genghini et dominique rocheteau remplace
bernard lacombe à partir de demain au
grand palais à paris l'automobile
française est à l'honneur pour marquer
le 100e anniversaire de notre production
automobile une superbe exposition a été
organisée qui durera deux mois
vous pourrez y admirer les plus belles
parmi nos ancêtres à 4 euros
christian blanc est mono
l'automobile a ses lettres de noblesse
elle le prouve aujourd'hui au grand
palais où les plus beaux fleurons les
constructeurs se sont donné rendez vous
pour deux mois
200 voitures représentant pas moins de
68 marque tout française qui se souvient
de ces belles machines réservé une élite
les delage hispano suiza torpédo budget
type en a en fait surtout ce qu'il est
fabriqué avec leurs mains six mois à un
an étaient nécessaires pour chaque
véhicule
il y as tout seul toutes celles qui ont
marqué l'histoire de ce pays
mais il fallait par ailleurs que ce ne
soit pas une manifestation passéiste
alors nous avons fait en sorte souscrit
une espèce de grande fête chaleureuse où
se mélangent tout à la fois les voitures
anciennes certes mais aussi toute la
technologie d'aujourd'hui et voir demain
les voitures d'aujourd'hui et entre
d'autres mains celles des ordinateurs
est le résultat du travail des robots
car la technique l'emportent et voiture
est devenue un bien de consommation
classique entre ce prototype est la
première voiture française la de la mare
de boutdeville un siècle seulement les
séparent la performance et l'économie
ont remplacé l'esthétique et la noblesse
les voitures des années 60 ont constitué
la transition c'est cette histoire qui
est racontée dans cette exposition
rien ne vous sera épargné l'histoire
sociale les économies d'énergie le sport
automobile comme l'affirmait le
président georges pompidou
les français aiment la bagnole
l'automobile reste bien la conquête
technique dans l'homme reste le plus
fier
alain gillot-pétré qui en est convaincu
va nous parler du temps de demain oui
mais j'aime bien les baromètres aussi et
j'aime bien les orages qui mijote c'est
fatal avec la température qu'on a
actuellement nous allons à l'orage
regardez la photo satellite
nous avons la marmite un art miz et
l'espagne voici tous ces ora qui
commencent à pénétrer doucement par les
pyrénées par le sud ouest et qui vont
prendre la france un mouvement enveloppe
pendant les trois jours qui viennent
cela dit l'anticyclone est toujours là
regardez la carte est superbe pour
demain c'est du beau temps partout matin
midi et soir
simplement des pyrénées hollande des
orages qui vont commencer à arriver ils
pourraient être localement forts
baromètre stationnaire thermomètre
stationnaire vaut mieux remarquer 23 28
degrés sur la moitié nord c'est tout bon
23 à 31 degrés sur la moitié sud 31°
surtout dans le sud ouest demain pas
deux minutes de soleil en plus ou en
moins pour ce mardi 19 juin levé 5h46
coucher 29 57 et bonne fête aux rondes
valdes pourquoi pas faim 3h15 c'est
jacques séguy qui vous présentera notre
dernière édition demain 12h40
cinquantaine de midi daniel bilalian
18h30 c'est la vie et j'aurai le plaisir
de vous retrouver demain à 20 heures
très bonne soirée sur antenne 2